is hypergamy on the decline
so there is some evidence uh for this um
which i think is kind of inevitable so
hypergamy is women's tendencies to mate
uh with an equal or higher status kind
of mate and uh i think it's inevitable
as more and more women become highly
educated and uh killing it in the
workplace that they will begin to have
to mate down and uh some some
evolutionary kind of based scholars
disagree with me on the fact that there
is amazing crisis at all and they point
to some of this evidence as evidence
that there is no mating crisis nothing
to worry about but even the authors of
that study that showed that hypergamy is
in decline said that they can't speak to
the perceived difficulty for women in
finding mates that they have to make
down with uh so it doesn't appear that
women are actually that what does that
mean
so
it doesn't appear that women are
actually that happy about having to make
down so
there's some evidence for this that uh
female infidelity is kind of on the rise
in lockstep with hypergamy so as
hypergamy is in decline
female infidelity not male uh goes up
male infidelity has remained pretty
stable over the last
50 or so years but female infidelity has
increased by 40 percent over the last
half century
and uh perhaps that's uh just an
artifact of them occupying more high
state dispositions being around more
high status men
maybe increased anonymity with dating
apps and things like that lower partner
satisfaction as well probably
yeah no longer reliant uh on uh you know
no longer having to worry about what
would happen if they did get divorced uh
another uh troubling finding from this
um consequence of the decline in
hypergamy is that a recent study of 21
000 women in 27 eu countries found that
women who were higher educated are
earning more than their partners we're
more likely to report all types of
intimate partner violence and that makes
sense from an evolutionary point of view
because men are most likely to kind of
inflict costs on their partner when they
feel like they might be about to lose
them so if their partner is earning more
than them and is around more high status
men
they're getting that cue and and they'll
they'll maybe shift to because when you
don't have much benefit to provide you
change to a cost-inflicting uh mate
retention strategy so that might be
what's happening there so it's not like
oh hypergamy's in decline
that's nothing to worry about you know
there's downstream consequences of this
and uh
you know the mating crisis overall has a
broader con consequences too because you
might have heard of something called
young male syndrome chris have you heard
of that that's the proliferation of
childless partnerless men roaming the
streets in gangs and graffitiing
everywhere and kicking grannies and
stuff right so if you have a surplus
population of unpartnered young men in
any society cross-culturally
cross-historically they've always been
extremely disruptive and you know due to
elevated risk-taking and status driving
kind of behaviors and so you know that
that
this kind of meeting crisis is dangerous
on a bigger level because that's uh what
we're leaning towards and actually you
know we would act although there is a
level of threat from in-cell violence i
feel like it's over uh overemphasized in
the media and a bit alarmist
but theoretically we should expect that
in cells represent a very dangerous
portion of society but what might be
happening there is that their status
driving mechanisms are maybe hijacked
just by online worlds and their status
driving in forums or [ __ ] posting on the
internet and getting kind of counterfeit
fitness cues from pornography that
you're an evolutionary success if you
stay at home jerking off to uh the
stimul the stimulus of
uh the sex on the screen that's an idea
put forward in a great article by diana
fleischmann called uncanny vulvas
the uncanny valley uh it's really good
read yes so what you're saying is that
the
young male syndrome which is this uh
phenomenon where lots of
men without partners tends to be
destabilizing for society could perhaps
be being dampened down by
online status by porn all of these
things that are kind of simulacrums of
cues that they would have previously
been super aggressive about but they're
kind of being sedated into
a more
domiciled version of this right yeah
it's like a pacifier pacifying effect
that uh but yeah yeah you mentioned
there uh
you had joe henrik on the podcast before
right indeed yeah so he wrote a great
paper called the puzzle of monogamous
marriage and he talks about how
cultures that began to practice monogamy
flourished more than those that stuck
with polygyny which 83 percent of human
societies that there ever has been or
have ever been studied have been
preferentially pollutionist and
joe henrik talks about it as in
monogamy's main cultural advantage is
the egalitarian distribution of women
and that that's a lot of listeners might
get uh get mad at me talking about women
as a resource but they're a reproductive
sexual reproduction sexual distribution
strategy man like if if man number one
gets women number one to number 10 and
then man number two takes woman number
11 to 20
after a while you can see how you
capture a lot of the market where a
visit one to one two to two three to
three four to four all the way along it
keeps more people more happy and
yeah going back to what you said before
about how um cultural preferences
mediate sexual desire or mediate mating
preferences right like what's held up in
the culture or something you could see
disney movies almost as reinforcing this
back in the day you know you find the
true love you go through challenges
there are things that try to tempt you
away and so on and so forth to see it as
to simply call disney movies a
patriarchal
presupposition cis heteronormatively
telling women about how they're supposed
to stay under the boot of men you go
a lot of what was happening with
constraining sexual desire previously
and having one man to one woman wasn't
just constraining female sexual desire
it was constraining male sexual desire
as well it was making sure that men
reached the threshold that they needed
to in order to be worthy of having a
woman if a woman gives away sex too
freely men will meet that criteria and
if the criteria and the bar is set
unbelievably low men will do what's
asked of them which is not very much
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]